According to research from Internet monitoring company DeepField,...
...Google makes up for 25 percent of consumer Internet traffic in North America.
It's more traffic than Facebook, Netflix and Instagram added together.
DeepField's research found that over 62 percent of devices connected to the Internet in North America...
...use Google servers at least once a day.
In 2010, Google reportedly accounted for six percent of Internet traffic,...
...so they have shown significant growth over that short time.
To facilitate their growth, Google has the second highest bandwidth capabilities after Netflix,...
...and they have increased the number of servers that they are operating.
Eighty percent of Internet Service Providers in North America have Google Global Cache...
...or GGC servers attached to them, processing information being used on the Internet.
DeepField co-founder Craig Labovitz said,...
"...The odds are, if you have an Internet-connected device,..."
"...at the end of the day it will be exchanging information with a Google server."
The GGC servers speed up the data recovery process...
...so that popular websites and videos can be accessed...
...without having to go all the way from Google's data center to stream the content.